Albert Breer is joining us from New York
the senior NFL reporter for the mmq b he
joins us McLovin give Albert our first
poll question okay if you had to sign
one of these non quarterbacks start your
team
I'll give you Erin Donald Khalil Mac
Odell Beckham jr. or levy I'm Belle
whoever top maybe Ezekiel Elliott if you
want to put the top running back no
Albert good morning good morning nobody
answered yeah and I actually I'm
bachelor it's all that clothes I mean
for me
Donald's such a unique player the
pressure numbers that he has here you're
like borderline unprecedented and it's a
valuable thing this is so hard to game
plan again you know Matt plays a premium
position outside brushes are really
important but you know you when you're
playing against the Raiders you can have
your quarterback get rid of the ball a
little faster you can do things pick
Odell Beckham out of the game
Aaron downs ability to get the
quarterback to disrupt things inside is
very very difficult the game plan
against and and if you do overcompensate
take care of him he's going to spring
weeks elsewhere and he's so close to the
ball you know I do think the uniqueness
of his talent because the way the game
is played right now I think Aaron
Donald's a guy who can build an entire
defense around it's very very very
difficult to pick out of games what's
the word with the NFL front office
personnel on Odell Beckham jr. contract
I think the Giants did a good job I mean
I you know you look at the deal and I
mean look 41 million
so I guarantee realistically all these
deals are really three years there are
only 52 and I say only in relative sense
but there's only 50 2.7 million over the
first three years of the deal that's
like over seven million dollars or over
over seven million dollars less than
Adamic ensued that's from Miami four
years ago you know so this isn't a game
changer it doesn't reset the receiver
market it's an incremental increase over
what receivers were already getting and
it does you know have a few trap doors
in there where I cut where you know
couple of years Giants aren't happy they
can get out of it so I think it's good
for Odell Beckham you know because he
didn't have to wait till the end of his
rookie deal to get paid and now he's got
some financial security going forward
yeah I think with the Giants avoidance
here is important which is you know just
completely blowing up the market that's
one of the reasons by the way that Coyle
mac and aaron donald art in Oakland in
Los Angeles right now is because you
know they're looking to reset the market
for defensive players but Giants were
able to avoid doing that on the receiver
mark with Odell who's the best receiver
in the game I still think it's a Antonio
Brown because I think you're Tonio
Browns probably the hardest guy to take
away you can play every different
position you can put them in this fight
and put them outside and I just I like
his toughness you know and I think this
goes for Julio too but yeah I think
Antonio Brown because you can play every
different spot and because he's very
very difficult to take out of the game
and because he's tough
and because he's been durable I would
take Antonio Brown over any of the rest
of them and I'm just talking about for
this year I mean over a five year period
you might be talking about something
else because sounds a little older now
but just for this year I think I'd still
think Antonio Brown I don't know if I
remember you being on record as to what
you thought of the giants draft strategy
that they obviously went say coin
Berkeley instead of Sam darn 'old your
thoughts on that as we get ready for the
regular season well I just you know
nothing on because I lost a coin as a
player I just I'm not sure about taking
a running back that high period and I
and I look back to the last couple strap
classes Dan I mean I you know Ezekiel
Elliott was a great player two years ago
for the for the Cowboys and wonderful
net out exact so disappointed enough
look last year the NFL's Russian
champion came out of the third round
Kareem hunt with the Chiefs and the
Saints got Alvin Kamara in the third
round and so you know it's not that like
I don't think that fake one's gonna be
great for it I think he's going to be
fantastic and I think it could wind up
adding gears to Eli's career it's just
that you know you you feel like at that
position you can find
really good talent later on the Vikings
got Dalvin cook in the second round last
year and so I think sake was gonna be
great like I don't think this yeah I
have no doubt that he's gonna be a
contender for Rookie of the Year is to
be a very very good player over the next
five years it's just hard for me to see
a scenario where if Sam Donald is what
the Jets think he is right now in late
August of 2018 where the Giants won't
regret not taking him in five or ten
years no matter how good sake one is
well I look at Mark Sanchez when the
Jets drafted Sanchez and they had a team
that was ready to compete they went to
two AFC title games but they didn't get
over that hump to make it to the Super
Bowl it just feels like you know the
Jets taking Sam Darnell they're not
asking him to take them to the AFC title
game this year or next year where say
quan barkley comes in for a team that's
ready to win now and I do believe
compete for a Super Bowl and it really
comes down to is Eli up to that task and
if he is then the Giants are gonna be
one of the better teams in the NFL right
and I've got three or four weeks more
years left and they win another
championship I mean since then until
proven to be worth it you know I'm not
sure they get there but if they get
there it'll proven they've been worth it
and you'll have been proven to be right
you know and then you'll have more time
to find the quarterback of the future
the what guy is gonna succeed gonna
succeed Eli I I think that's the idea
here
and I understand what they've got old
men in pass Shermer doing the idea here
is very similar to the idea in drafting
Ezekiel Elliott for the Cowboys two
years ago when the Cowboys drafted Zeke
it was to try to extend Tony Romo's
career now obviously you know the
circumstance has changed there and
everything else but when they drafted
him it was let's take the burden off of
Tony Romo it's fine
easier completions for Tony Romo let's
get Tony Romo hit last and they felt
like they could extend Tony's career by
bringing begin to the fold and kind of
shifting what they were offensively now
things changed and Zeke wound up being
that for a rookie quarterback right like
Zeke wound up being that guy for dak
Prescott taking the weight off at that
class cotton using his transition in the
end
well so I think the concept here is
similar where Eli doesn't need to be a
top-five quarterback of sake one is what
they think is and he can make everyone
better he can take the pressure off of
Odell back up you can take the pressure
off of that offensive line you take the
pressure off of Eli and make everybody
better and so I understand the concept
in it it's just I mean I don't know
about you but it's just tough for me to
wrap my arms around the idea of passing
on a quarterback if you think that you
can be the answer for you for the next
15 or 20 years now look if they didn't
think that's what Sam Sam Donald was
then buy that that's a different
argument but if you're talking about one
position versus the other I think it's
it would be hard to justify taking a
running back over four but although I do
understand the logic and doing it and
why this was an Eli friendly move he's
Albert Breer senior NFL reporter of the
mm QB and NBC Sports Boston
speaking of Boston why is Tom Brady so
sensitive about this topic about his
trainer I mean these are fair questions
here aren't they yeah I think he's just
sick of hearing it
you know I mean look this is a difficult
thing for him this is a difficult thing
for the Patriots and I mean I credit to
them for finding some way to compromise
I'm sure you guys saw Carrera wasn't a
team playing last week I give him credit
for finding a compromise because this
was not an easy place to find a medal
this was not an easy thing to find a
middle ground on you know for Bill and
for the Patriots coaching staff and
teachers for ball operation
you know once the Guerrero thing went
beyond just Tom Brady and Rob Gronkowski
Julian Edelman you know what the
recruitment of other players and now you
had you know 15 20 guys going to see him
I know that the staff here was worried
about how that would would undermine
their strength coached on the flip side
if you're Tom Brady you look at this and
you say to yourself well wait a minute
I've eaten crap for 20 years for you you
know I've taken hard coaching not taking
less money I've enabled your program in
so many different ways I made it work
when there's been less talent around me
and now I just want this one little
thing to set up what I'm gonna do for
the next 20 or 25 years of my life and
can't give me that
and so
both sides had solid ground to stand on
it was a really hard thing to find a
middle ground on and it feels like now
they have found that they're gonna go
forward into the 2018 season I think you
very clearly see the fatigue that Brady
has after going through all that is
there a chance this team implodes this
year it's it's a long fuse and it feels
like it's lit I just don't know if it
actually implodes
yeah just for forever again I think that
you know Brady doesn't provide margin
prayer Brady has been there margin for
error they had left town on defense last
year and you look at the guys who walked
out the door Jamie Collins and Chandler
Jones and they were able to get by
because Tom Brady's their quarterback
you can go back you know to 2011 same
deal bad defense to get to the Super
Bowl 2006 he had no receivers around him
they let David Givens go they trade
beyond branch right before the season to
get to the AFC Championship game forever
and ever and ever
Tom Brady has been the margin for error
for the Patriots he's been their cushion
they can make mistakes and he can make
it work and so I have a big question
here when you look at their roster is
it's not as Tom Brady is still going to
be a really good quarterback I think you
will be it's if he slips a little bit
and he's going to be free and he's 41
years old now but if he slips a little
bit can he still carry that weight on
his shoulders that's a fascinating
question I think going into this season
because you look at what they're going
to be rolling out their receiver and
they're telling us they have issues
right like they let go you know Eric
Decker retires they let go of Kenny but
they've been cycling through all these
guys I think you know the big question
now is you know you look at their issues
on offense and how they're gonna have to
try to make it work there and issues
they had last year on defense and
question isn't is Tom Brady gonna be
really good if the question is can Tom
Brady still carry the entire operation
41 years old
the anthem policy it feels like both
sides are kind of quiet there was some
news that came out yesterday they're
still trying to figure this out what's
what's gonna happen
I know ESPN is not going to show the the
national anthem I believe on all their
games I don't know if the other networks
gonna follow suit but where are we
headed for a week one of the regular
season on this topic
I know there's been there's been a push
from some owners to do nothing and I
know that there are some owners despite
the unanimous vote there really would
have liked to see the league do nothing
in May and we're against things going
the way that they went and could see all
of this coming could see that you're
creating all these different news cycles
who's standing who's staying in a locker
room who's kneeling
what's this heinous policy vaccines
policy they could see all this coming
and you wanted it wanted to do nothing
back then and so you know I think that
that's a piece of this that there is
that argument out there in that room
like why don't we just do nothing there
aren't that this isn't a huge issue for
us wasn't huge issue for us the end of
last year you know there's also the
feeling that maybe we can negotiate this
out maybe there is something we can do
for the players maybe there is some sort
of give back do this all like all this
stuff is still on the table and but the
interesting thing about it is I think
we're nine days away
season opener right now we still don't
have a resolution and so I think as we
get closer the possibilities they do
nothing becomes stronger
and if they do nothing of course I think
you know that we'll probably get some
sort of response from the Oval Office
and then things could get really
interesting so they've got an
interesting 90 days ahead of them I I'm
not sure exactly what they're gonna do
my understanding is the toss have been
mostly amicable but clearly they ever
found a resolution yeah but what is do
nothing mean what would what's the word
then leave it the way it's been you know
and I actually I'll give you this nugget
from inside the realm and a you know I
talked to one owner who who had said who
you know he told me like he was all for
doing nothing and he wound up voting for
the policy that went in at May but he
said to me yeah and kind of whispered to
the guy next to him in the room in Bay
but why don't we just do nothing you
know they sort of started talking about
it and the other and and this other
owner said well the problem is what if
you know Trump has another
sons-of-bitches moment and then we don't
have a policy on the books then we got
cops Latvia cops
I think there was a push back then to
have something on the books something
enforceable on the books the problem is
that you know when you put something on
the books and they say well not
everybody has to enforce it and that
doesn't really do much of anything and
so I you know what there's sort of I
think support both ways for this there's
there are certain people feel like you
have to put something on the books there
other people who feel like they should
do nothing and the one thing you want to
remember here to Dan is this subject for
those owners is intensely local and a
lot of people are talking about the CD
rating with the national revenue all
that stuff that's not what this is about
yeah this is intensely local and the guy
in Dallas of a dying Houston the guy in
door I want to say some different
circumstances locally than the guy in
New York the guy in Philadelphia the guy
in San Francisco and so that makes us a
very very complex thing for the owners
to sort through because each of the
individual guys is dealing with a
different set of circumstances I'll
leave you with this I heard about this a
couple of days ago when I was on
vacation about there's gonna be a push
eventually to maybe go to three
preseason games and then at us you know
a 17th regular-season game then I see
this morning where Jerry Jones is
talking about hey two preseason games 18
regular-season games I know that the the
collective bargaining agreement is in
place till 2020 so nothing can happen
before then but where are we headed with
regular-season in pre-season well you
know I think that here's what I like
I think there's been that focus from the
owners and this has been pushed on the
Commissioner to get to that 25 billion
dollar number in total revenue and you
know this would obviously help nudge
things in that direction there's no
question of what help III think what
what could be interesting here is if the
owners are willing to change some of the
rules for the players as far as free
agency goes if you're a player this is
the way you got to think about it right
it's gonna if under the rules the way
they are right now for me to become an
unrestricted free agent I've got to make
it through 64 games and considering all
the injury stuff and everything else
that's top if under the current
circumstance you have 18 game seasons
that becomes 70
to Dean's so I think one of the things
the players would owner will put what
Marvel in this case is okay help me get
look like make me invested veteran after
three years and let me get on restricted
free agency after three years insured
and rookie contract so guys can get paid
quicker to me that would be one solution
where you know now you'd be talking on
to the Mac I'm not sure but I think B 54
games maybe maybe the owners trade off
and say okay we go to 18 games but we'll
let you get the free agency quicker and
we'll make you bested veterans quicker
to me that could be a sensible solution
if the owners really are intent on get
they good stuff Albert we appreciate it
thanks for joining us that's Albert
Breer senior NFL reporter the mm QB and
NBC Sports awesome for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]